[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
joining us today very happy to share
with you what we've been working on with
SRA practices stackdriver and the sto
service mesh my name is jay jutka whit's
I'm one of the lead PM's in stackdriver
at Google my co-presenter Tim Kelton is
co-founder head of sre operations and
security at decart labs a customer of us
and so we're gonna learn a little bit
about what we're doing in the product
and then see what Tim is doing over at
the cart so the purpose of everything
here is to help people adopt sre
practice and to have the same kind of
efficiency operationally as we have at
Google and so we're not gonna be able to
do the presentation without starting
with a quick overview of SRE
then we're gonna dive into sto sto is a
really important ingredient for tying
together the sre practice and the
stackdriver toolset as well find Tim
will come up and talk about what decart
found in in real life trying to manage
their their application at scale and and
how these technologies going to come
together help them we'll talk about the
stack driver integration with this do
specifically and then we'll get into a
demo who here is at the keynote this
morning and so it was his demo all right
so we're going to see that but in more
detail and on Tim's stuff instead of
Google stuff so brief overview of sre
Google has eight products with over a
billion users on them we manage that
with an SRE team of 2500 people so not
that it works this way but that's over
400 thousand users per operator which is
is pretty crazy economy of scale and and
you know ability to get the most out of
out of out of folks now the challenge
that the sres have is how do I keep
everything super reliable of course
Google calm is kind of synonymous with
is my internet up but at the same time
Google has this reputation for
innovation right at the zillions of l
a-- pers writing all these applications
doing experiments pushing things up
pushing the envelope how do you balance
the need for availability and
reliability and performance with the
need for you know moving the business
forward in innovation that's that's what
the s eries are about so what are what
have we found are the ingredients now
this isn't an SRE talk the s eries would
do a full hour on this so I apologize to
anybody watching on YouTube later this
is going to be a a very brief overview
but and this is the observations we
found from the from the stackdriver
tooling side like when we observe s
Ari's what do we see makes things
special first off is is a culture sres
aren't just running around with a pager
trying to squash bugs and react to
problems it's very proactive
organization they they engineer the
reliability into the products so pretty
much all the work they do its front
loaded way before you ever have an
incident they're automating processes
for monitoring and and and automated
remediation so that things hopefully
don't get to a page there they're doing
production readiness reviews with the
end with the application team's
applications
can't go into massive scale and have s
where you take the pager unless they're
engineered for liability
they're setting the principles of
monitoring and alerting they're managing
the customer promises whether they're
internal or external the SL O's which
you'd think I'm going to talk about
right now but we're going to push that
off a little bit later till we talk
about the SLO feature but that's like
the most important thing and of course
they do manage the Incident Response
when there is an incident very scalable
flexible and predictable process called
I'm at which you can learn more about in
the book and they're responsible
responsible for the blameless postmortem
culture that we have which is really
important you can't make things
continuously better if people aren't
comfortable saying what's gone on saying
what went wrong
without fear you know you know if
they're afraid of retribution so that's
that's kind of a brief overview the
essary culture now for that culture to
work they need data everything yes Ari's
do is data-driven
is it working well is it reliable is it
cost effective is it is it gonna scale
without the data nothing works
so can you imagine so the SR use like I
said we've got great economy of scale
and that team they're outnumbered over
ten to one by the developers imagine the
s eries went to every development team
and said I want you to put this metric
in this metric and this metric and this
metric and put it here here here here
and here short conversation right it's
not I'm not going to go very well so
what we've done at Google is we've
actually engineered the sre practices
into four from telemetry at the least
into the platform itself so when a
Google engineer on an application
deploys application code it's not just a
container or a VM it is a service it's
it's got a beginning and an end it's
identifiable schedule as a unit it's got
a discoverable API with a known contract
and it's got security and quota
management already available to it and
it's got the telemetry standardized
telemetry so that anything about that
service is sent back to the monitoring
systems so this is pretty cool
so this allows sres and the software
engineers to actually be much more
collaborative because we're not pushing
work on one another we put the worth of
the work on the platform you deploy the
code everything works now there's a
little bit of oversimplification I'm
sure Google engineers will say it's not
always that easy but it's pretty good
approximation so now what we've done is
well you all can all develop on Google
or you don't work at Google but we try
to do is we try to externalize the
concepts that we have into products in
the open source so our container
scheduler Borg is available as
kubernetes the concepts we're going to
talk about ISTE oh that is basically an
external in
inspired by one platform our API
management system our secure RPC system
is externalized is G RPC and our
instrumentation the things that actually
send the metrics traces and whatnot it's
something called census internally
externalizes open census so not only if
we tried to make this available for
folks to use on Google but because it's
open-source
we let you use it on competing clouds
let you use it on on Prem as well so
hybrid multi cloud version of this
opinionated infrastructure
that'll make it super easy for you to
manage applications as service as a
collection of services rather than a
bunch of infrastructure you know
willy-nilly
we're not gonna talk about this much at
all but as you can imagine with all
those engineers reading all that code
sending all those standardized metrics
we got to put it somewhere so we have
systems inside Google
that's scaling and we get petabytes of
logs a day we have billions of of
monitored resources hundreds of billions
of time series and this same system is
actually the basis it's the bottom half
of stackdriver the part of stackdriver
yangtze so when you use stackdriver
you're actually storing your metrics
your traces with the state then the same
kind of system that Google is storing
their own lastly what this presentation
is really about is the tools you know we
want to have this culture change you
know the you know deal with monitoring
by SLO and you know working off of this
standardized platform with the
standardized signals well to make that
all happen you have to have tools to
bring it all together there has to be
great UI and workflows that let you see
what you've gotten be able to use it and
and that's you know kind of the tip of
the iceberg right you know you always
see the iceberg and the thing on top is
what you see so those first three
columns there's a lot of work in there
and and we're gonna describe the the tip
of the iceberg and show you the tools
that we're building so with that we want
to drill down on sto to show of hands
who here has heard of this deal before
fantastic I guess that's why you're in a
room who here's used it before
oh wow this is great so I will do a
brief treatment of sto because again
this is not an sto talk just but the I
do encourage people to go to the sto
sessions as well so with people have
started breaking up monolithic
applications into smaller and smaller
micro service applications you know the
prototypical - pizza box team you
started creating a lot more
communication between a lot more pieces
of software and that creates a lot of
problems right if you had one monolithic
piece of software yeah you put the
security in the quota management and the
the instrumentation you just put it into
that monolith and be done with it
but now if I've got tens or hundreds of
micro services I don't want to do that
again and again and again and again I
just want to do that once and be done
with it and that's what sto provides it
provides security for micro service
communication so that community as the
security becomes configuration rather
than baked into the code it provides
operational agility so you could say hey
I want to have this traffic splitting
you know 10% go here 90% go here I want
to do the canary I wanna do the rollback
I wanna you know manage how the traffic
flows again that that comes from sto and
lastly the uniform of visibility uniform
observability because sto is is in this
place this service mesh that's available
to all services the cert the mesh itself
collects the metrics and traces and
sends everything to to the monitoring
system of choice so this service mesh is
what creates this this open system for
being able to deploy code as services
and manage it through config rather than
more and more and more you know software
logic in terms of the architecture so
the key thing here is the envoy proxy
the envoy proxy is what's abled is
what's sitting in between service and
service and it's what lets you
it's where the the metrics for the API
are captured and unable to be sent off
the proxy is also able to call out to
the mixer for things like quota checks
and security checks and the mixer then
doubles also as an aggregation point so
instead of having to have a zillion
streams coming back to your monitoring
system being able to to batch those up
and send it back in a sensible way
lastly you have a have pilot that is
pushing out the configuration everywhere
so that we could have as many stateless
pieces as possible and citadel which is
dealing with the the identity and and
security pieces so that is a brief
overview of sre brief Oh Rio Vista oh
very theoretical to this point so let's
see practically how does Tim use this to
make the cart better thanks Jay
[Applause]
so just as sto is focused on providing
visibility into your services and what
is happening between them and how they
interact decart Labs is actually focused
on improving visibility and
understanding of changes that happen
every day all over the earth and we all
over the globe and how those changes
then might impact our customers their
businesses and even their their global
supply chains and we accomplish this
through a building of machine learning
models and those are fused together with
many different types of geospatial and
remote sensing data and those such as
satellite imagery or aerial imagery so
you can kind of think of that almost as
somewhat of a service level indicator of
monitoring changes in all over the earth
and we're a start-up that's actually
just a few years old our headquarters
are up in Santa Fe New Mexico way high
up in the mountains and we don't
actually have any data centers we don't
have any physical servers so the cloud
has been this critical component for us
as far as infrastructure we could have
never built something on our own this
quickly as just a couple year old
startup and we have nearly 15 petabytes
of satellite imagery and our machine
learning team needs to scale models over
tens of thousands of cores on any given
day so whenever possible we really push
to use managed services we're heavy
users of gke we also use stackdriver for
a lot of our monitoring logging tracing
all of those types of things so how do
we build these service level indicators
for the whole earth well we do this by
building machine learning models like I
said and pulling together this imagery
but it's also not just about having a
single source of data most of the time
the accuracy in our models
is comes about from combining geographic
data across large geographies often
through many different spectrums of
light not just human visible things like
infrared near-ir sometimes we'll use
remote sensors and things such as
synthetic aperture radar or signals like
that and then it's also large temporal
windows it's not just hours or days but
sometimes we're actually spanning and
building models and testing them back
over over decades and no one data set
usually will just be the answer so in
some ways this really isn't that
different than understanding what's
going on with your micro service it's
often the fusion of data for many
different services many different
sources together that give you a full
picture of how the application is
actually interacting and so decart labs
models pull together internal data we
pull in public data so you could lots of
imagery from NASA or Landsat also
European Space Agency but we also pull
in many commercial data sets we have a
lot of our own data but we try and pair
the data with what will provide the
biggest answers to provide context and
our goal is to scale up building of
models over massive geographic regions
over many different modalities and over
really large temporal windows to provide
that insight for our customers some
examples would be just last Friday we
were running models and looking at
building how many looking at hurricanes
and Florida and things like that we were
able to quickly scale out and build
models and identify every single
building in the whole state of Florida
in just a few hours so what does kind of
our architecture look like well we're
very gke centric on our micro services
we have around 50 micro services we have
as I said around 15 petabytes of Earth
observe
and sensor data most of that is actually
stored in GCS we have some core key
services that that can selectively pull
just parts of the objects from GCS it
could just pull for example a single
band of light and just be able to query
that and we we have to be able to scale
and those compute jobs individually to
tend the tens of thousands of cores and
our micro services the we have we use a
wide range of data persistence tools
besides just the object store that's on
GCS we impair the micro service with the
appropriate back-end it could be cloud
SQL or BigTable or or any of those
databases and we leverage a lot of them
for each service but all of our
monitoring logging and tracing is is
then back into stackdriver
so what are some of the challenges we
face with scaling micro services
probably like everyone here who's had a
lot of different services one of the
biggest things is visibility visibility
understanding of the source code the
components what was deployed with each
of the micro services how each of those
micro services then start to interact
together how how many times do you does
a black box tester maybe use one
intended use case but then this micro
service is is really valuable and
somebody else finds out about it another
developer starts using it in a totally
different way that you never intended
and so when my application changes
another problem how do I quickly observe
what's going on will have applications
that are configured with a variable
maybe was changed downstream and there
was a huge consequence it didn't show up
in early tests maybe it changed the
traffic maybe the service to service
interaction is now different so if I
release a new version of code how do I
gain understanding about like did this
improve my efficiency on the back end of
the service so what's what's really
needed prior to this prior to ever right
a service level agreement for any of our
customers we really have to kind of
understand the performance baselines and
the behaviors of the actual application
and how its performing in in real world
with real load traffic so what matters
or is noticeable what matters or is
notable what it might not make any
difference to the customer you know we
might have built metrics and dashboards
but the uncustomary can't see the
difference it could have problems still
how do how do all the components of the
service then work together how can I
easily track how many errors are
acceptable for our our customers when we
need to stake when do we need to take a
step back on our development roadmap and
and look at instead of maybe building
new features we need to improve the core
stability what does the product manager
have to figure out those types of
priorities so overall in some ways then
when we move to Sto this really isn't
super different and this is kind of
Awesome
you know I am NOT putting
instrumentation libraries into every
single micro service that we have out
there there is that approach and I could
do that but we have services written in
a number of different languages and I'm
guessing many of you do as well and so
with sto as Jay mentioned earlier one of
the keys is the Envoy proxy and we
inject the sidecar proxy in with the
micro service and that gets deployed and
you can actually set that up to happen
automatically so when those pods get
deployed the sto the Envoy hike our
proxy gets reported in and then that
metrics starts going into the back end
so this starts to give us instant
visibility into each service which
services are calling that that specific
service it gives us service to service
authorization we can do things like we
might need to rate limit a service for
example I like to use off as
as a really good example it's okay if it
gets hit five times a second from one
pod to another pod but if it starts
getting hit 20 30 40 thousand times a
second from a pod there's probably
something fishy that was going on in
that code and I would want to go check
that and overall we have now all of our
services are talking back into the back
end sto control plane with the pilot and
the mixer as Jay was mentioning and and
then we have been envoy and just
injected into each of those containers
and so with that thanks so much so
alright so we're gonna talk a little bit
about the products that we built like
what we've done to stackdriver to be
able to better monitor sto with all that
data which we had I won't go into gory
gory detail because we're just going to
show you with with Tim next who's gonna
come up and show you what the card looks
like but there's three problems we
really wanted to solve first problem is
what the heck am i running what is my
service architecture I can look at it
from a code perspective right I can look
at github and see all the different
source files and and you know I maybe
look at a build system and see what what
the what the artifacts are but that
doesn't tell me anything about the
infrastructure I can look at the
infrastructure and look at VMs and pods
and containers and that tells me what
I'm consuming but it doesn't tell me
what I'm running what what I really want
is you know how many of you have had to
train a new hire what's the first thing
you do you go you go to the white board
right you go to wait board and you draw
a picture you say all right we have this
thing here which does this function and
talks to that thing there's talks to
that function which depends on this
thing over here
and it turns out humans have an
incredibly intuitive understanding of
what makes up a complex system and we
wanted to do was be able to make it so
you don't have to draw that on the
whiteboard but instead got that
automatically and that's what the
service graph is about so we're able to
you know if we had to build this up from
random pods and containers not so easy
but because this do is a
about where service starts and ends and
it's able to track which services are
talking to which other services it's
actually I'm not gonna say easy but it's
certainly a lot simpler to build this
graph and that's what we've done is
basically graphed out the entire sto
service topology now we've done a couple
other things here that are important one
is we've added a time element so how
many of you have ever had to tech
support for somebody you love or care
about right what's your first question
what did you change and what are their
first answer nothing and are they ever
telling the truth no so on the bottom
there's a time slider and so that time
slider lets to go back in time and see
you can go see okay what did the service
look like 50 yeah you know an hour ago
would it look like two hours ago see
where the changes come in also this
doesn't replace all of your dashboards
and everything but you have basic
metrics for each service I mean what are
the golden signals what do people care
about what is my traffic what are my
error rates what are my Layton sees of
various percentiles you get that at a
glance and that's really really
important because let's say you get a
support call about something at the top
of the tree do you want to go debugging
that thing right away maybe but maybe
not maybe it's actually the thing it
depends on has problems so if you say
high latency on something up top and
then you look at its five dependencies
and you go oh wow
one of those five actually has high
latency down at the bottom I bet the
high latency at the top is caused by
this this one thing down lower then you
can go debugging right at the at the
source of the problems so this is an
excellent triage tool because it gives
you an at a glance view of all this
stuff and then lastly it lets you drill
down it doesn't end at just a service
list it actually you can double click on
these and go down from the from the
workload level to the deployment to the
replicas set to the pod to the container
and actually see if it is an
infrastructure problem which pieces of
infrastructure you can want to look at
problem number two how is my service
behaving well you know again you can
look at it there's a lot of different
fractured points of views of this
you could look at dashboards which show
you a lot of different metrics about the
infrastructure response rates or
something like that and that will give
you one idea or you could dive deep deep
deep into the code itself and go okay
what does the distributed trace look
like how is my latency distributed
between different micro services that
make up the app but again you're not
getting a big-picture view of it like
where do you start with how do you build
your conceptual model and this is where
we're actually going off to the I
promised I deferred the SLO conversation
to hear what you really want or at least
what we want at Google is service level
objectives for each service so think
about how many servers and how many
containers are running at Google imagine
if every time a CPU went hot and
necessary got paged I would never work
right I would never scale no 400,000
users per se at that model so they
automate a lot right they automate the
the auto scaling so okay the CPUs go hot
you Auto scale CPUs go down everything's
fine nobody gets paged but you can only
automate so much you automate first
thing the next thing and the next thing
and the next thing and at some point you
get to something that didn't get
automated away and the customer
experiences pain that's what we want to
measure we want to learn when does the
customer have pain alert on that and do
something so the first question is what
is the service level indicator what is
the thing the customer notices and cares
about there could be a hundred answers
to that question but there's two that
come up again and again one particularly
for API based services one is
availability what percentage of my
responses come back with two hundreds
the second thing latency performance
right let's say a customer needs 300
milliseconds response time on an API
okay
what percentage of API calls come back
with 300 milliseconds or less
those are your service level indicators
a service level objective is when you
put a target on that when you say I want
99 percent 200 responses a week or I
want 99.5 percent 300 milliseconds or
less response time these service level
objectives are
now the promises that were making to
ourselves about our service
it may be communicated externally it's
often not now but it's but it's
important because without those
objectives really hard to figure out
whether you're doing well or not now you
notice I didn't say a hundred percent
right if I wanted a hundred percent
reliability
we'd never release anything so the the
the when you take a hundred percent -
the target that's your error budget your
error budget says yeah how much how much
slack do I have this period so if your
error budget is really super high you're
not spending it what happens when your
boss gives you money budget and you
don't spend it by the end of the year do
you get that money get in the next year
no they take it away so budget is there
to be spent and so if your air budget is
super high all the time well maybe it's
time to release more code maybe it's
time to do more experiments maybe it's
time to see if you get more features out
to your customers because if it's more
reliable and your customers need they
prefer features what if the air budget
is really really low well you may want
to hold off on that big release right
and what if your air budget is still
within limits but dropping precipitously
wake somebody up right because otherwise
you're going to be below and you're not
going to be happy so the air budget is
really how the s-series live and die and
how they have they how they organize
their lives and how they know what they
should and shouldn't do
you have a contract with your internal
or external consumers you measure it and
you you know and you uh you work based
on what you look as measurement show and
then of course you can get a complaint
there could be a get a report at the end
you could say okay did I meet this SLO
for this period
now these hellos are pictures from from
stackdriver so one of the features that
we've got so the first feature was the
service graph that we showed you second
feature is this SLO feature so both for
App Engine which isn't really a part of
this talk and it's do we're letting you
put where we're making it super easy to
put service level objectives on your
services measure them and get the graphs
automatically and and then be able set
alerts and know when to page people
based on the
those problem number three debugging so
who hears you stackdriver before all
right how many you see how many I mean
if a small room I'd ask how many parts
he can name or is metrics and logging
and traces and profiler and debugger and
dashboards and error logging and I'm
probably skipping a couple it's a pretty
broad product so and they each have
their own screen right so I can go to a
metrics screen I can go to log screen I
can go to a trace screen but if I'm
debugging a problem in a particular
service I just want to know everything
about that service don't show me all the
other stuff show me everything I care
about about this service in one place
scope to the time of the problem and
that's what we've built with the service
dashboard so the service dashboard has a
number of elements which you're gonna
see in Tim's demo in a second it's got a
timeline slider up above which shows all
of the relevant events you can open and
close the time slider to get to the
around the events and care about and
around the time you care about and that
filters everything else that we're gonna
talk about there's events on the side
that give you more details about what's
been going on and then there's these
tabs and so the first tab is SLO tab
pretty important because we're starting
from when you're debugging you always
start from the broad and go deep right
so the broad thing is oh my SLO is error
budgets dropping okay that's the
broadest all right what's the next level
of depth metrics so for any given
service we could say all right here's
what the response rate is us are the the
transaction rate is here's what the
latency distributions are and then we
let you slice and dice that so you
oftentimes the servant doesn't just
flat-out die right what usually happens
with the service is some subset of
traffic is broken this version from this
sender in this location right you want
to be able to slice and dice the traffic
and figure out who's the outlier right
who's the subset of traffic that's
making the overall thing bad and so the
metrics the service level metrics about
availability and latency let you do that
now once you figure
out what subset of traffic you care
about you can dig into Diagnostics right
let's look at traces let's see what the
different percentiles of traces are
let's go into that maybe it's not a
performance maybe it's an availability
thing so we want to look at error
reports and see you know what kind of
stack traces we've got and then there's
everybody's favorite the least common
denominator of debugging logs when all
else fails read the log files so with
this we're able to go again from the big
picture of the service graph say hey hey
who's which service is likely at fault
down into that services dashboard find
the SLO to the service metrics down to
the individual diagnostic pieces
ultimately we'll also want to include
debugger and profiler and have you know
launch off into there but you could
imagine how that would add on later so
who wants to see Tim show you the
product instead of me talking and doing
screenshots yeah all right so please
switch alright so I am coming in I'm
brand new I'm a new sre I like Jay said
we could whiteboard this all out but now
my services are actually injected with
the Envoy sidecar proxy they're all
reporting up into the sto control plane
and I can start going in and exploring
like what does my service actually look
like I can start trying to understand
are any other services calling our
service so like I said earlier we serve
lots and lots of pixels or imagery it's
also known as raster's so we have a
service called raster and this service
just as a background this is a Python
flask application that's hitting GCS on
the backend and I can see actually it
looks like I have two types of traffic I
have data going to the metadata service
and then it looks like I have some
client requester from black box so I
mean I actually didn't know no one
told me in the documentation anything
about this metadata service I'm just
trying to learn so I'm gonna actually go
look up you know what is the metadata
well in our case metadata is information
about each scene you know which bands of
light which time was this this was this
image taken maybe which sensor was it
was it from NASA or something that would
be the types of information that we
would store and metadata and in this
example like we have the backend of
metadata we've made a an index to be
able to look things up and as Jay
mentioned you can start to see
high-level I can see some requests
accounts I can actually also see here
this is I don't see any traffic here but
oh this is non 200 responses so that's
actually good that I'm not seeing
anything and I can also see response
latencies and and right dive down into
you know what are my long tail events
there but this is just a high-level
overview then one thing to point out
because I've this'll this is just a
off-the-shelf or nutty off-the-shelf
open-source elasticsearch server so
that's open source code that I'm not
adding any sort of libraries or metrics
to instead I'm just sitting behind the
Envoy proxy so now I know that we've
made our SRT SRE team wants to throw
requested traffic that we know about so
we made this black box tester and that
actually uses our Python client and it
calls out to these services
it looks like it's now calling to
metadata and raster I can see that from
the traffic traffic side and so that's
that's the use case that I've seen at
this given time so now I'm going to go
look at an SLO that I've I've made this
was over a week and I'm looking at the
SLO for our raster service or I'm sorry
this is over the last day and I'm
looking at all the tale events I can
start to see that oh it's actually
right around that that service level
indicator why that threshold that we
said it's 99.5 percent of that indicator
and now I'm looking at the error budget
it looks like we were actually really
good and until early and late last night
and then it looks like latency started
just dropping off and our error budget
is actually starting to go down and
actually I'm starting to see now that it
looks like it's actually declining more
I can also like dive into some of the
events that happened earlier today it
looks like there was an event around
just before noon I can see that we had
some incidents but now I want to
actually zoom in and say actually what's
going on right now and it looks like my
service has actually dropped quite a bit
below and I actually have a big problem
right now I need to figure out what's
going on and I need to basically stop
the bleeding to some extent I'm seeing
Layton sees dropping well below what we
were hoping for I'm seeing we're burning
error budget I'm seeing our service is
out of compliance basically it's it's
kind of all hands on deck at this point
so what I'm going to do on the back end
I've seen that that raster is where all
those core requests are coming in so I
actually am going to probably we didn't
set set our HPA's correctly maybe we're
not scaling on the right metrics maybe
we need something more specific but I'm
going to scale this up and just try and
get the service back it back in
compliance and so so while these pods
are all initializing I'm making a whole
bunch bunch right now while these pods
are initializing is as was mentioned
earlier I can start diving deeper into
the problem I want to get a better
understanding of of what are actually
the metrics that we're seeing and so one
thing I can do is I can actually because
I know which service is talking to which
other sto knows sorry I don't actually
I know at this point but I can actually
group by something like the source
workload name another thing I could do
is I could actually look at response
code you know I could say just show me
the 200s for example if that if I knew
all my traffic but I actually know
there's a problem
so I want to see you know is there are
all the workloads hitting this API the
things I know about or is there actually
something new coming in and then I can
scroll down and I can actually see that
there's a new service that's hitting
some developer got the wild idea that he
knew how to use my API and he was going
to make this killer app and he is
basically crushing that single pod so
that was never gonna scale in my Layton
sees were going to basically drop off
and I can start seeing though here that
Layton sees are getting slower and
slower so hopefully my now I've added
more back-end raster pods I should be
able to start handling that load and now
I might want to go in and dive even
deeper the next step I would do is I
would actually want to look at the
Diagnostics themselves so these are some
of the the requests and the the
percentile and the latency and I can
actually see a sampling of what some of
those calls to raster where I can
actually start going in and seeing you
know here's this raster service and I'm
seeing the slower times these were in
the 90 and 95th percentile and I can
actually start seeing the full traces
one thing to mention we've actually I
can sync click around on a few of those
and and that starts we've actually
implemented I can look down at that time
window and I can actually see some of
the logs coming in and I can look at we
are having some problems it looks like I
can see logs relative to this this small
time window just to this service it's
already kind of filtered that down for
me I didn't actually build any of these
these dashboards or widgets so that's
really helpful here I actually see some
good requests I can actually see we
served raster imagery looks like this
was a metadata request to a NASA Landsat
scene so so that's really nice to be
able to compartmentalize that oh and
look I just now am seeing an incident
pop-up I am seeing I actually have an
error budget I'm losing error budget and
I had now have a new incident so I might
want to start understanding that so now
at this point hopefully we've started
stopping we've stopped the bleeding so
at this point I thought it would be
helpful to just show actually how I make
a SLO to begin with since all of my
services are behind sto I can actually
use the service service graph or the
service Explorer and I can actually see
all of those services themselves and so
I can actually go find the excuse me I
can actually go go find the which
service was this ok i am in the roswell
kubernetes project i'm picking good new
mexican names that's a city in new
mexico if you're not familiar and i can
go look for let's see where is as well
so oh sorry oh I'm already selected that
I've self selected but these are the
popular these are we're all populated
from misty oh so now that I've actually
I've laid that rest or service I can
actually add an SLO and I can do an SLO
with two different types of service
level indicators one would be
availability maybe my application always
has to be up like that's what's most
critical for our line of business in
this case I kind of just showed you
we're serving all these varying sized
imagery and really what what crushes us
from day to day maybe is is latency and
how quickly or how responsive that that
service actually is so in this case what
I'm going to do is I'm going to make
this service respond with 4,000
milliseconds or four seconds and then I
can pick a period in real life I would
usually often use maybe a month or at
least a week in this case we're building
a demo and I'm showing you just walking
through how we build these so I'm good
I'm gonna actually select just just one
day and then finally I can pick a target
compliance you know what's the
percentage of traffic that should be
served what do we do when the latency
falls off this this falls lower than
this amount it starts being a really bad
experience for our customers and we kind
of want to do something about it so in
this case I think I'm going to try 99.5%
of the ANC so in remember this was just
over a day so 99% of that traffic that's
if I broke 99% up in minutes that's
about seven and a half minutes of the
day that the latency can't be below so
that's actually probably probably pretty
high it might be too aggressive I'm not
sure I'm gonna actually see now this is
really nice because what's happened is
they've looked at the the traffic coming
in between those services and I didn't
pre populate or pre build this it's
actually pulled all their request
latency and then I can see where I
on that 99.5% threshold you know is that
was that really the right level to put
on a service level indicator actually I
think that that's not doing too bad I'm
looking pretty good there and then I can
see what what my error budget would have
been and then I can finally see you know
where my compliance would have been and
this is this was a demo cluster we have
you know we've only been running load
for a couple days so that's that's
actually why this this load stops
showing previously there so that's just
a walkthrough of how you can get started
building SLO s once once they're behind
is do so at this point I think I'm gonna
check on incidents and and I'm gonna see
if I have any any incidents and look I
actually have budget loss incident it
started it's now been going for seven
minutes if I had setup stackdriver
paging or alerting based on that I would
have that would have started setting
we've started burning through the budget
the error budget right there so at this
point what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna see if we have if we
if adding all those raster pods did that
actually help anything at all I'm going
to expand the this service bar out and
then I'm going to look at what what's
been happening with my a solo and I just
want to zoom in really really close and
it actually looks like I'm starting to
see latency now begin to improve it was
it reached bottom it looked like it was
getting around ninety eight point one
five percent but now finally latency is
starting to get better I was burning
error budget I'm hoping that that error
budget has now stabilized and we're
starting to flatten out you can see I'm
now out of compliance
so hopefully these changes will start
scaling more and more pods and at this
point we'll start going back into full
compliance and so at this point I think
we've walked through all the major thank
you so much Tim so all rights to see
I've got two and a half minutes what can
I tell you so just just to recap the SRA
practices are awesome SDO is platform
technology that helps you get there so
that you don't have to build all the sre
practices into each microservice
yourself stackdriver
automates the creation of service graph
automates the creation of dashboards
automates the the graphing of SLO s like
Jim showed you just have to supply the
target and it takes it from there
hopefully this gives you the the best
possible visibility into your services
and also gives you the best possible
mean time to resolution when when
problems do occur I definitely encourage
you to see some of the other talks that
are out there and we're in early access
for the software that we showed you it's
not generally released yet so if anybody
wants to take a picture of that link the
the shortened link that's the survey to
apply for the software to to get early
access yeah so thank you very very much
for your attendance really appreciate
everything and thank you Tim for for
contributing you would not believe what
this guy went through last week so so
thank you everyone and enjoy the rest of
show
[Applause]
[Music]